so
thank you all for coming jared thank you
so much for inviting me it was very kind
of you
um just a quick show i'm going to
practice your show of hands for a second
so who here knows
what our vloggers is okay
so we know each other that just answered
who your users are
um another show of hands who here has
used in his work in any point of his
career
h-plus okay
uh however who here knows what
hierarchical clustering is
okay so we know what that is we haven't
done it much
so here's the last question which is
actually what i was aiming for
uh i'm trying to decide how much to
drill into
the code and how much to go high level
so who is in favor of going like really
going into
some code raise their hands for a second
okay who here is more like
i know when i can't see uh just talk
with me hi there
okay we're embarrassed to stay
so i'm going to start by giving a small
piece of context to
the work of them so i'm going to present
to you today two packages of
uh authored one is then extend the
second one is installer
both talks are relatively lightweight
talks uh but
uh somewhat pretty the
motivation i had for studying then
extend which i'm going to talk about in
a moment
was that during my master thesis i had
to do compare
comparisons between two philogenetic
trees
and for that i imported one tree and
then i needed to construct another
hierarchical clustering tree and compare
the two
and i discovered that that is a very
painful process to do an r and doing
that
work i've developed a lot of code and at
the end of that
project i said why not package it into a
nice neat package
and this is going to be the result so
i'm going to assume which is a bad
assumption i see
but i'm going to assume you know what
hierarchical clustering is and you know
how to do it with r to some degree
and i don't need to explain it to you
and i'm going to go through some of the
caveats of what is currently
accessible to you in base r and then i'm
going to go into what i've offered this
is not going to be satisfactory for you
to know how to do it on your own however
all the slides are already on github
including a vignette which is about 80
pages long
so you're going to have all the
information needed even if you don't
have the background
even if you're not very good at r you'll
have all the back all the information
you need to go through it
at home and do it for your own data sets
so let's start with
dendrogram objects okay so h cluster is
the method used by
r so i'm saying something else h cluster
is a method used by r to create our
hierarchical clustering but once you
have that data object
but once you have that object you want
to do something to it you want to
visualize it you maybe want to
manipulate it a bit
and that is much easier to do in denver
grounds so
i want to start by the disadvantages of
the ending so the disadvantage of a
dendrogram object in r is that
there is no statistical method to create
it we need to go through h class to do
it
and the other major disadvantage is that
there is
terrible performance issues when you're
working with dendrograms in general and
the reason for that is because the
dendrogram is
well a tree and when you want to do
manipulation and to program
something on a tree you need to use
recursion
and whoever here has experience with r
knows that loops and recursions is not
our strong side so that is a caveat
part of it i treated while but by moving
to rcpp and doing some of the coding in
c plus plus and this way i mitigate some
of the problems but that's a basic
problem we have with environment however
dendrograms as they come
with base r already comes with many
advantages and they are that
there are many methods for doing stuff
with endogenous we're plotting
dendrograms for printing dendrograms
um you can
show dendrograms with more than uh two
branches
to deal with non-binary trees which
h-class for example cannot do
and the data structure of the dendrogram
is relatively easy and i'm not going to
go through it in details but i'll say
it's basically a list of lists
with attributes to the nodes saying
which members it has in each node
and a few more added attributes that's
that's what dendrogram is it's a very
for a person experience with our it's a
very easy data structure
compared to h class which is more
complex and
the other advantage of dendrograms is
well it's both an advantage and a
testimony for it
for how useful it is that many packages
use dendrograms in its processes and
this is just
a partial list so
that said dendrograms still have much
more to go
and by doing this package what i've done
is i've assembled
pieces of code from the internet some of
them were answers to questions i've
asked you in my work some of them were
work done by other people i won't go
through all of the credits i will give
two major credits because that's
probably the most amount of work
that i've incorporated into my code and
one is um
to give credit to jefferies which i
don't have his full name but he
created the dendro extra package which
i've modified quite a bit but that was
the lovely work and the second thing is
they are quoting because
so much of what i've done uh took from
examples they
have scattered around the web and so i
can't really give credit to a specific
person but basically they've done a lot
of work
and lastly to my advisor i've been
immunity allowed me to do this on phd
money um which i'm not supposed to do
so then the dent extend package has
about 89
functions this is a little uh
mapping of the functions and how they
interrelate you're not supposed to read
that
and let's start with looking at what we
can do so
let's go into something so this is an
example which is very boring
but we need something to work with so i
took a data called precip which is
basically
the amount of the water amount of rain
in a certain year across cities and i
subsided to take just boston new york
because that's where i was in a few
other cities and then i created a
distance matrix matrix between
these cities and each one of them is
just one number so it's a very
the distance is very simple simple to
understand then i run in a radical
clustering of this distance
and i turn it into a dendrogram by doing
s dendrogram and i reverse the
dendrogram for some other reason and
here's just a simple
uh showing of what the data is so
washington is 39
centimeters of rain for that year
millimeters new york is 40 about 142 and
so on
and on the right you can see that i
plotted the dendrogram object and this
is
this is how the object would look like
so i'm going to assume you that you've
understood everything that i've done in
this slide because if you didn't then
some of the things i'll do
but that's very simple that's very nice
before you assume you know what the
demogram means how should we
read that image okay so i
that means i can't so should i go
through give me a sh and i'm sorry i'm
doing this
but i have half an hour should i explain
that image give me a hand for a second
who wants me to explain that image
okay so i'll briefly go about it so a
dendrogram
is basically a representation is a
partial representation of a distance
matrix
okay that's what it is you take the same
way you want to do
dimensionality reductions many other
methods this is one made
one way of reducing the amount of
information you have in a distance
matrix
into a visible visible plot that you can
think of
okay so in our case you know the
distance for example between let's take
the
example here so we have washington and
new york so washington and europe the
distance between these two
cities with these two numbers is one
okay so how does that apply with
a dendrogram so you would go here and
you would see that here you have
washington and here you have new york
and the branch
is in the height of one has the height
of one and that signifies the distance
between between these two cities in our
data set
the problem is then that if i want to
continue this iterative process of
creating the tree
i would need to throw away a bunch of
data so for example the next process
would be to
compare boston to these two cities and
when i do that i need to choose which of
the distances
boston to watch washington and boston to
new york which of these two distances i
should use or how can i aggregate these
distances
into the height of this mutual branch
and the way it's done here is through a
method called single which is basically
giving me the minimum distance between
one item in the items of the second
group so that's what it gives us here it
gives us two
and the reason for that is probably
because boston has a distance here we
see
boston has a distance of two from new
york and three from washington so two is
smaller than three and we take two
and this is how in an intuitive way
we construct a dendrogram so it's a
representation of a distance matrix
which can represent many many different
things
okay thank you for asking um
so let's talk about the types of things
we would like to do with the dendrogram
object and
and here's an example of a long list of
functions and and
features now available through the
dendixtend package
so one basic thing we would like to know
is to know how many leaves we have in
the package so
you can like you have end call and
enroll you now have the leaves
function that gives you five we have
five leads
end nodes is how many nodes we have in
the tree including the leaves so here we
have nine
nods so this would be the first not this
would be the second
the third the fourth and then we have
five more so that's fine
um and and this function
i'm giving it because i want to try to
understand something about
how all of the functions work on
dendrograms so i said to you that the
dendrogram is basically
an r object which is a list of lists
with attributes
so right now one very important
attribute is what is the height of every
branch of every one of these nodes
and and the answer is that it depends
where we are so in this knot the height
would be 14.
at this knot it would be about four and
so on so how can i
access all of these attributes in an
easy way so
the answer is that you would need to run
a recursion function it would go through
the list to be able to extract all these
all this information all these
attributes so i've packaged a bunch of
recurs
such recursive function into several
functions
so this is a function called get not
attributes which does what the name says
where
i put into it the den object and then i
say give me the attribute of height
and what it then does it goes through
one knot at a time
from top from top left to right
okay so the first nod was 14
the second one is this one it's left and
bottom it's
four the next one is two the next one is
one and then we have
this knot which is zero it's a leaf zero
zero zero zero okay
and that would be highly important for a
lot of different things you might want
to do
later with dendrograms and the same
thing can be do with another
which is members which says just how
many leaves there are underneath a
certain
tree a certain branch of the tree and
then another one which we're going to go
deeper into is labels underscore colors
which says what are the colors of our
of our labels in the leaves currently
they have no color
which is how we get the dendritic
objects
let's start adding some color okay so i
have
i'm going to assign the then object we
have into a new object called then
two i'm going to take the labels of them
to
what its current labels were the names
of the cities
and i'm going to assign to that labels
the aberration of
of of the labels meaning i want to show
them the labels
now notice that just this move is not
currently possible in r
you could not assign and when you think
about this object you can understand why
they didn't
play around with doing it to begin with
because it takes a bit more
uh work and often people may not need it
okay but in order to just assign levels
i actually need to go through their
cursive
a recursion of the of the trioness and
find the right labels and assign them
which is not a big problem but no one
said it did it so now you could do it
and and then we have labels underscore
colors of them which was nothing
but to that i sign now a rainbow rainbow
hcl colors
with the number of leaves meaning i'm
giving it five
five colors into these labels and then i
plot it
and this is the plot we get so we get
the same plot
just with nice colorful colors for the
labels
okay that's nice let's do another one
let's call it the branches and this is a
bit more complex
so here what i do is i assign then three
with what we just had but this time what
i do is i
i assign to it the object end
to after after entering into
the function color branches now this is
a bit different this way of working
which i think is the right way of
working with dendrogram is a bit
different than what you might be
accustomed to in many other
r objects and many times what you would
do is you would have one object let's
say a linear model or something
then you would have a plot method for
that linear model object
and you would just have many many
parameters in the plot to change
to get the type of plot you want when it
comes to dendrograms what you often
would prefer to do because it's so
expensive on
on time because it's so slow is to take
the object itself and
keep modifying it but keep the modified
version of the plot if i were
to keep doing all these different
changes to a dendrogram over and over
and over it would take a long time so i
would rather
change the labels and that's it that's
my new dendrogram object a dendrogram
with colored labels
and then you're going to it branches and
so on so we are copying this one
after getting it into the function color
branches with k equal three and what
does that do what it does
is it says let's take that dendrogram
and
cut it at a certain height that would
give us three different
clusters from that dendrogram so here
what we can see is i i plotted
then the dendrogram and i did a line at
the height of three and consider that
the height of three
this cuts our tree so that we would have
one leaf
okay it's from this this green line down
this is the second leaf from this uh
green line down
but here what we have is we have another
third branch
okay so we have three clusters so the
first cluster has
miami the second one would have national
and then these three cities would be in
the third cluster
and what the color branches do is that
basically it says how
do i color the branches of the tree so
you would easily see
the cluster identity of each of the
branches and it's easy to see that there
are three colors right
we have blue green and red for each of
the three colors
let's move on this one i'm gonna skip
and this one i'm gonna go into so this
is also a simple function hang dot
dendrogram
and if you're wondering why i'm using
dots sometimes in underscore sometimes
i'm not going to go into it but there
are good reasons for it
um not great reasons
aesthetical decision reasons for it
but what i do here is i hang the tree
what does that mean it means i take the
leaf
the leaves and i and i take them as high
as i can before they
they go beyond their branch and why is
that important because sometimes it
helps us understand that certain
two certain leaves might be much more
distant
than is visible in the way that they are
ordered so here what we have for example
miami
is just by nashville but by hanging the
tree by giving the
the height of the leaves to make it
higher and closer to the
original branch we can see that actually
miami and asheville are quite
far apart from each other whereas
washington and new york are actually
quite close
so that's a nice way of visualizing the
distance to make it easier
next another thing we want
we might want to do is to rotate the
dendrogram so currently there is a
function to do that in
r called reorder and i would strongly
recommend you not to ever use it
and the reason is that we're used to
thinking about the order function in r
when we want to reorder vectors or
matrices
and we we assume that if we'll put you
know that the id
of a certain item it would reorder
according to the item id that's not how
that function works
it gives some sort of weighting a
way of giving weights to every node and
then it gives a certain function of the
weights and then it aggravates it to
decide on their order and that's not how
we want to reorient the tree basically
we
would prefer to just take the tree as is
and just tell it
what is the the id numbers of the labels
i would like to reorder or just give the
names
of the labels according to the order i
would like them to be at
and that's what the rotate function that
we see here
offers us so we just place into it
rotate of the dent object and then you
just
put the item ids of the leaves into it
and then it just
rotates it the way you would want it to
be so you can see that here i
i asked for the fourth item to be first
so what is the fourth item from left it
would be
miami here we can see that miami is
first on the
on the on the right tree we can see that
miami is first and then the left one
was in the fourth location and that is
that impression
in nashville was natural sorry hi you're
right
sorry
the next one is unbranching and
unbranching means that sometimes you
might want to take that was my
particular case in my work where i had
um actually needed to take two trees
combine them
the both of them together but i didn't
really know the height
of the combined tree and actually the
the branches in the trees that i combine
actually should have had
the same height so i wanted to unbranch
them so this is what this function does
it basically
tells it allows us to take dendrogram
and
take one of the one of the branches and
and put it to be at the same height
as the root as the root of the tree so
here you can see that this new tree has
three children and it's written on
instead of two
and the sen and the next one is to prune
we sometimes want to take the tree and
remove some of the
items and that's that's something that
should be done
with caution the reason i'm saying it
because uh one of and
not going deeply because of time
constraints but a dendrogram object in r
uh is a list of lists with a lot of
attributes but at the bottom of the list
what you have is numbers and these
numbers are integers indicating
the id of the location of that data item
in the original matrix
that created the tree okay that's what
the dendrogram object numbers
mean and when you start pruning this if
you had five items then you would have
numbers from one to five but if you
start pruning the tree you would start
having a tree with the numbers
one three and five and if you have
something like that
and you put it into h plus and you play
around with it it would crash r
uh which i submitted a bug report and
didn't get any responses so
be careful when you do it and just save
everything
but the the function does what it's
supposed to do it would only be
problematic when you start transferring
it back into h-cluster objects
which right now you couldn't do because
we have uh we have here true
which is not a binary tree so h plus
wouldn't be able to eat it
um okay this is actually a show function
but it
it took a lot of work so this is cut
tree so country is a function you would
use an h clust
to cut the hierarchical cluster in a
certain height
and distinguish the cluster identities
of of your items
and i've implemented that function to
dendrograms and that takes a lot of
a lot of work which was which produced
very slow code which is now
made much faster thanks to rcpp and
thanks to romain and
dirk which are not here but they're
incredible with the work they've done
um and it acts exactly the same way that
h-clust function would act
meaning you would then it would work for
the method for h-plus you would just put
in the then
it would say k equal three and it would
give you um
a vector with the cluster identity of
the items and the
items names as names of the vector um
and then there are nuances which i'm not
going to go into but there are a lot of
nuances as to how the order
of the cut of the elements in the
country are produced the order of them
could be different so country would want
one thing
and for certain functions you might want
to reorder them according to the data or
according to the way the
tree is the order of the labels of the
tree meaning
that right now in this tree we see
nashville boston and miami and their
order is one two
three but it could be that in your
original data matrix that created these
objects their order was
five two and three um
so the question whether or not you want
these names
these cluster belongs to be in this
order or the original order of your data
it's a big question when you're playing
with these objects and so be
careful with it if you didn't follow
that's okay just just notice the third
thing so let's take a prettier example a
bigger example so here what i have is a
very
very classical data set called the
aristotle set so we have
150 items each item is a flower and for
each flower we have
four parameters we have the height and
width of of two types of the
leafs entire inside the on the flower
petal and settle septal which i'm not
sure how to pronounce i'm sorry
um and that's a very classical dataset
given
to us by fischer and and that dataset
was both used for supervised and
unsupervised learning
and what it shows you when i take this
scatter plot matrix
and i color the 150 dots according to
which of the three species of
flowers they belong to i can very easily
see that well
if i were to try to do a prediction
model a supervised model i can i would
be able to
separate let's say the blue the green
and the red i would be able to
maybe maybe regression maybe something
else i could do this
um um
i would be able to to cluster there
around
however if i were to not tell you the
colors of the
of these dots and ask you would you be
able to tell me how to separate these
data
these points into three i'm telling you
upfront that there are three species of
flowers would you be able to tell me
just by this scatter plot without the
colors
to which uh to which of the species
each flower belong to and the answer is
that well for these
blue ones you would be able to do it but
here you would have a problem you you
don't
you're not sure how to separate your
date and that's a known problem in the
rs dataset
um and i'm now going to re-show you the
same the same effect when i'm doing it
in a dendrogram
and what i do is i basically um take the
distance of
each of the items from one one from the
other using their
uh therefore parameters and with that i
have a distance matrix i can represent
that then as a dendrogram
and then because i have a dendrogram i
can say well i can cut it in a certain
height it would give me three clusters
which is exactly what i've done and when
i do that i can then give colors to each
of these clusters
and i can try to see if the
the way that i'm clustering the data
based on dynagram is a good way of
clustering
but in order for me to see that i need
to also know what is the true
uh species for each of the flowers so
the way i've done it here is that i've
given the label colors to be the real
the real species and the real species of
each of the flowers
but the the the branches are colored
according to the way that the clustering
method is done so we can see that
actually for this for this setosa
species of flowers
these for these blue flowers we've done
it the clustering did a good job it was
able to separate them as was
evident to us in this scatter plot but
when it came to
the ver vericicolo philogenic i'm sorry
if i'm not saying it correctly for the
green and the red
uh we can see that well the clustering
has a lot of red
branches and some green branches however
the labels don't fit
so we got we got most of the green right
uh but with the red i mean when we
said about something that it's green we
got it right but when we said about
something that it's red
we have a large cluster of green dots
that we misclassified that we
would have misclassified and of course
you can tell me well why would i need
dendrogram for that we have a scatter
plot
well you could use a scatter plot when
you have uh just
four dimensions and that two specific
two dimensions are very useful to see
that
you're not gonna do that when you have
ten dimensions or one hundred
however you could do that with a hundred
dimensions so that might be useful to
look into
um and that is the promo of my next part
so according to the clock i finished my
time i was not able to talk with you
about the install r package
so what i'm gonna do because we started
a bit later i'm gonna still about four
minutes
is that okay i need the speaker to
approve where is john
sure so i'm gonna steal about four
minutes i'm not gonna talk at all about
this
but i'm gonna say while wave enhanced it
all this work was done in order for me
to be able eventually to compare two
two trees and and to compare trees you
would need two things one is
you would want to have statistical
methods statistical
uh measures that would allow you to
to know whether or not the two trees are
similar or not to to say are they
correlated or not
so i've implemented several such
measures and also have done permutation
and bootstrap methods to allow you to
test the validity of that but what is no
less important is to be able to
visualize that to people who don't know
what you're talking about
and for that you have the tangle ground
plot which just takes
two it takes two trees in this case it's
the same iris data set that we have
one was created using the the complete
method one was used using
you was created using the single method
and i'm trying to show you
the similarity between these two trees
or the dissimilarity between those two
trees
and and part of the way i'm doing it is
by clustering
them in height at the height that would
give us three clusters but also by
coloring the lines that connect between
the items with the real
species identity of each of the flowers
so this allows us to easily see that
both the clustering methods are doing a
great job with the blue they're both
doing
a terrible job with well they're both
succeeding with the red
but they're both doing a terrible job
with the greenhouse complete seems to be
doing a better job because we see more
green with green
and here we see almost no green uh with
me
and i'm not going to go into how to plot
them i'm not going to go into how to
rotate the plots in order for them to
look prettier
which is something i don't have time to
do but that's
how i would want to do it one moment
but that's something i would eventually
want to do to reach something like this
it would be
trees that look prettier so there are
many functions
in the package to allow you to
systematically go over and do that and
all these
slides are available online so you'd be
able to go through the slides the r code
that created the slides
and the vignette that also presents
these things and there is another set of
slides showing you how to
compare and do some sort of inference on
the measures
that said let's go into powerpoint
and do this or not
and do view i'm sorry i use a non-mac
computer is that full screen it says
that it's full screen
operator to what play
play of course
no i apologize
yes now right i press play
really that's how we do it ah you see it
differently okay that's fine
um so i'm going to talk about the
installer package really quickly and
this was a lightning talk in the last
use r
so i have five minutes i could do it in
five minutes i know i've done it before
so let's do it um the installer tries to
solve the following problem
we want uh we want to update
r on windows and here are the steps you
would need to do to take in order to
update on windows
so the first step is we need to go to
the our project website
we will need to see that there is a new
version of our just released because how
would we know it otherwise
then we would need to go to the other
side of the page press download then we
would need to choose the crm mirror
which i would
suggest using star studio one then we
need to choose the
the link well in our case for windows
then we would need to know for some
reason
we would need to know that we need to
press space which i have no idea how
people are new to are supposed to get
that
uh and after we press space well
then there is a big link which is nice
to say download our we might want to
jump over to see the news
and then we want to install are we done
do you think
what's the answer no the answer is of
course the way i'm asking it of course
the answer is no
and the answer is no because the next
steps would be that we need to
deal with our packages because if you
all you did was to reinstall a new
version of
r what you would get is you would try to
run your code and you would see that
none of your packages exist
so what you would want to do then is you
would want to copy your packages from
the old library folder to the new
library folder but
while you're doing that you must make
sure that you're not copying the high
priority packages that come bundled with
r because if you do that
then you would use an older version of
these packages also
after that you want to do update
packages with check build equal true
because that's what you need to do for
example when you move from 2 15 to
3 to 15 3. and that's it that's
that was easy wasn't it so let's make it
easier
so what you would do instead you can go
and install the package install r you
would load install r and then you would
have a menu item
there you would press update once you
press update r would go for you for the
internet it would check
if there is a new version if there is it
would announce yes there is a new
version for our for you to download
do you want to download and install it
and and you would be able to say yes it
would ask
you do you want to see the news the
recent news in the art
in the new r version if you say yes it
would send you to the browser to see the
news
and once you press yes it will download
r and
run it run the installer for you and you
could then install r and after that it
would ask you do you want to copy your
uh your packages from the old version to
the new version of r and then it would
ask you do you want to update
the packages and each of these steps in
the in the package this is actually the
pet package i started with to learn how
to create the package of that extent
so i did it as a pet project just to
learn how to do that so
uh each of these functions are actually
have a back-end
our function which would be update i
would just
do the entire process check for update i
would just tell you if there is a new
one or not
and copy packages between libraries
would copy connections between libraries
and so on um and
since i already created the package i
thought to myself well why not you know
start bundling a few more
cute things into it and one of the
things i found useful that
of course some of you may not use
windows but you have friends who use
windows and you might want to help them
install r and when you want to help them
install r you might also want to have
them
use rstudio you might also want to have
them use miktef if they want to use near
or s weave you might also want to have
dev tools if you want to install
packages from
github and so on and each of these
software packages we need to you need to
go and download and instead what you can
do is you can just use these
functions install that our tools install
dot r studio and so
on and forth and that would just do that
for you it would just
go to the go online download the file
and run the installer for you
and if you want it easier then you could
just press install software from the
menu item and
give you the options of softwares that
you can install using r
and another step
um and this might be well it's useful
for me i use dropbox and sometimes i
i like turning it off while i work
because it keeps throwing me error
messages when i use it
with our studio so what i do is i turn
it off but then i go
i finish my work at the university and i
want to go home
and i remember that i need to stay
around until the computer
finishes to sync the dropbox with uh
with
the new files i've created um so what i
would like to do is i would like my
computer to go to sleep after a certain
amount of minutes so i've just created a
fun you know
nice little function that does that and
the reason i'm telling this is not just
for the people who use dropbox but if
you're having a long simulation running
for a long time
you would have this function called os
dot shutdown or is that sleep and so on
that you could use that you you would be
able to just put at the end of your code
if you're running a long simulation that
would do it for you if you're going
out for the weekend and you're leaving
your computer and you want it to be
uh sleeping after it's done and back up
your output
um i won't go into this this is this is
just a nice
bunch of functions to download and show
use is
download statistics of packages i'm not
going to talk about it
but it exists and there is a post i
published about these functions a while
ago and our hyphen statistics if you're
curious
these are the list of the top downloaded
packages in r
i'm not going to go but on that also
also and i'm not going to talk about
that but that i'm going to say
thank you so much